at the White House yesterday President
Trump answered questions about Syria and
Turkey and his decision to pull back US
troops I think we're doing a great job I
think the people of this country I
campaigned in ending the endless wars
we're all over the world fighting wars
we are doing the right thing and I think
the country feels that too we've had
tremendous support outside of the
Washington little Washington area and
even in Washington people are saying
you're doing the right thing at least a
dozen Republican senators have publicly
criticized the president's decision Face
the Nation moderator and senior foreign
affairs correspondent Margaret Brennan
joins us now good morning Margaret based
on your reporting is it your
understanding that the president has a
support from people within his
administration and national security
team on this issue no the Pentagon and
State Department officials all the way
up to the Secretary of State had argued
for a much stronger response to prevent
turkey from harming US allies in Syria
but this policy is being driven by the
president's conviction here he is
totally convinced and solely focused
that he needs to pull out US troops and
this is despite official warnings from
the White House that it had opposed the
Turkish invasion it was what President
Trump said on that phone call to
Turkey's president air Dewan that can
contradicted the u.s. stance because he
agreed to pull US troops out of the area
and that was seen as a green light
Margaret we heard the president threaten
major economic consequences for Turkey
if it goes too far what exactly is the
red line here well exactly no one's
defined too far generally this is a
threat of sanctions but US officials are
concerned by a few things one that
civilians are getting killed that the
Turks are gonna target Kurdish fighters
that the u.s. fought alongside and in
the future what happens to all those
Syrian refugees Turkey's air Dewan has
said and suggested he wants to push
millions of them who fled the war back
into this border area and the US wants
that to happen in a humane way if it
happens at all Margaret is it possible
that US troops could be drawn back into
the region it always is in the Middle
East you won't lose money betting on
that but I'm told in this particular
case Turkey zeratul one
is not expected to stand down he is
hell-bent on this invasion and the focus
right now is on just how far Turkish
troops go into Syria and if it extends
beyond the safe zone because there are
still roughly about a thousand troops US
troops at other locations in that
country Margaret what happens with the
Isis fighters who were being held by the
Kurds what's likely to happen to them
well there are two in particular that
have gotten a lot of attention the
so-called beetles that the US and the UK
are negotiating over them because they
were directly involved in the killing of
American journalists including James
Foley they may be extradited back to the
US but the UK has to agree other
high-value Isis detainees are being
moved from prisons that had been jointly
secured by the US and Kurdish fighters
into military prisons but the challenge
for months now is that there are
thousands of fighters whose home
countries strip them of citizenship and
now many of those European countries are
refusing to take them back so it's the
fate of those fighters and their
families who are living in camps inside
Syria that many people are very worried
about because the concern is that in the
chaos that will result from this
invasion it could allow Isis to regroup
all right Margaret Brennan thank you
Margaret